[Music]
and baby fever news baby fever fever
fever fever baby fever fever fever baby
that damn enormous ah baby shark yeah
yeah but I don't got kids kid to know it
really I only know what cuz everyone's
been singing I was like what the [ __ ] is
going on and then I watched enols at
home you know who taught me that song my
ex she got a kid no she's just light to
that song oh you're the one that told me
that's not even a new song had a new
song it's an old song oh yeah what what
was it something else and then they just
put those lyrics now it's literally that
baby is getting nominated for a Grammy
this year oh is that what it is I think
she learned it in [ __ ] um like
cheerleading or some [ __ ]
what from Kareem gross what I thought a
Korean song she submitted by Joseph
spelled Chue s Eph Yousef the first ever
mom baby the first ever monkey has been
selected for Gerber's 2019 campaign Wow
- Dom Holmes y'all out there in
Sacramento Fresno in Minnesota
Minneapolis the only diva Minneapolis
I'm just curious why they decided to put
an H in front of everything complicate
things if you put em Ong that just
that's mom yeah and then our language to
[ __ ] cut knife yeah that's true why
do we do that well in his article he
said it's pronounced Hmong with the you
yeah Mon yeah Mon yeah Mon Tatum on tato
[Laughter]
even funnier could you say to the same
level
I just learned that Hmong people don't
have a country
yeah I didn't know that you thought they
were Mongolians no I didn't know you
know I'm saying cuz I mean I knew I'm
really from they are kind of hill people
traveling around the history is there
there they're actually southern Chinese
people that got excommunicated from the
country because they had their own
Kingdom and when they lost the war they
got pushed into Southeast Asia they went
into hiding
do they have their own language yeah
yeah mom they got strong-ass jeans too
cuz they all look the same
among person I'm not young I guess I
don't really know because I used to um I
used to mess with a among and in French
girl and well cuz yes free jeans yeah
yeah they roll deep I've only seen like
mungs in threes fours fives you ever see
me well I've never seen a single mom
person dude you should know this during
the northern area of Thailand that's my
first rule because I knew the wrong
people like in the States but they live
in like Fresno not not in LA right I've
type ride I don't know these mo there's
a joint among people in northern
Thailand really yeah like by the border
of Burma and all that second ball in the
in the hills of Southeast Asia that's
where they live sup my Yang's my bangs
my hers those are those are the typical
last name cuz they don't live in hollow
there yeah they wrote and they they're
all deep - yeah they're like in like in
house
monk a tornado the prominent religious
shamanism - is kind of cool
all right so yeah they be [ __ ]
killing chickens during [ __ ] weddings
and [ __ ] yeah the shaman Samba doesn't
think that they do it's pretty cool yeah
like ghosts and stuff all right so this
15 month old baby named Kyrie
yeah I read yeah Kyrie Kyrie Kyrie named
after the novartis Oh character oh oh
she won the Gerber photo search judges
oh my god dorable yes so the judges said
that the photo they submitted the
parents submitted of her like they fell
in love with it because she just looks
like you could see the curiosity and
wonderment in her eyes yes yeah she's
she looks like a baby fish yeah oh yeah
so here's some more photos oh he's so
cute yes she's from North Carolina
she knows her angles too yes pop in her
hip out she doing one of these things
with his shoulders yeah so she's um
she's now the 2019 Gerber baby she's the
first grabber baby of long descent well
as I've been in like just a Asian at all
um there may be it there might have been
an Asian one or else they would enough
focus so much on the multi mom yeah well
there yeah that's pretty much what's
making headlines that she's Asian zone
longs don't get any please sleep by
themselves you can't tell healthy make a
three-month-old sir he is three months
old why he sweated a [ __ ] man-sized
jacket Oh car baby a little bit Hmong
guard long guard
how about I have a picture wearing those
clothes okay yeah good mommy we got the
biggest [ __ ] family to man they got
so many siblings and they all D they
wrong that they live with
pretty much the entire family Oh
interesting the world beat I'm learning
so much today
one of the happiest times I had was
living in a hmong village man really
it's like a party every day dude where
did you when and where in Thailand so
around what else 13 or 14 I went on his
mission trip and then I went to Thailand
and then they were building like my my
my church was building churches and just
they were helping out the villages of
these poor monk communities because
they're also not citizens so they've
been living in the hills for a long-ass
time but they don't get like aid from
Thailand e oh because they technically
aren't a part of way so yeah they're
just basically like refugee hillbillies
but they've been there for like I guess
hundreds of years they've been there for
a while right but they're not considered
Thai people right so then they have to I
don't know something like they just a
lot of them have opium fields or like
they have to do those things cuz they
still need money
you know um yeah so when we went to all
these different villages man it was
crazy like you drive up and then on the
side you'll just see a whole field of
opium like poppy hmm that they're just
back there that they're growing for the
drug lords and [ __ ] but like it's just
regular ass village people you know like
they got pigs and [ __ ] walk like all
over town like and I'm like how do you
know which one's your pig and which ones
not and they're like oh when we you know
kill the pig everyone just comes and
eats so they made like a big-ass pig
soup thing and the whole village just
came down and everyone got like like
little bowls and stuff and it's like
that's why it's like when a different
house like has a bunch of food or
whatever like everyone just comes down
and gets food yeah it was pretty cool
how long the other four then you had the
real - come on dude
Wow month yeah it was it was hot as [ __ ]
and it was cold as [ __ ] and I got what
time of the year we went but like all
concern the mountains yeah cuz like in
Bangkok and stuff it's like super humid
and tropical right yeah when you go into
the mountain zone yeah yeah it's like
freezing cold at night and then in the
daytime it's like blazing hot and you're
like what the [ __ ] is his weather and in
the the homes that they had were just
look just straight-up made out of wood
like it was just like if you're a ball
and you had like wood you know
it looked like a cabin almost if you're
not like dude was a dude that was still
living in a hut like yeah we call him
uncle drugs because this fool had like
three teeth and then he had this long
pipe and he would always be smoking
opium right okay he could he was
probably like 30 years old but he looked
50 cuz he was like still ripped right
and then um yeah we just called him
uncle drug cuz he was happy as [ __ ] and
he was like smoking that [ __ ] and he
will play like this one one stream the
air who thing in the morning and then he
lived he literally lived in the [ __ ]
grass hut that he built himself yeah
okay three teeth yeah there's a ton of
stray dogs it's cute as [ __ ] right
there's a lot of stray dogs and in doses
one puppy that that we've wrapped around
a like red ribbon and then one of the
dudes backed up into the puppy it was
[ __ ] sad as hell so the puppy died
masked it
yeah well the puppy got hit with the
tire and then but the puppy wasn't like
dead dead he was kind of like laying
down and then just slowly passed away
sorry because uncle drugs was one of the
biggest warm-hearted [ __ ] on
earth right he saw that we were all sad
so he dropped his crack pipe his opium
pipe right and he got up he rushed over
to us and he did this stop thing like
this and he was like doing sign language
just to us and he moved over and then he
[ __ ] got the puppy and then we all
followed what he was gonna do with it I
was like that that [ __ ] better not eat
it or whatever with his three TiVo and
then he [ __ ] started digging and then
all [ __ ] so like he's gonna bury it so
we were trying to help him he like no
I'm gonna do this myself everybody's
still alive the puppy the puppy would
died in front of us yeah and and so he
started digging and digging and digging
and then he put the puppy and then he
[ __ ] buried it and then like we all
kind of like prayed together and he was
like he was like the what do you call it
like the the mortician or the he was
like the he became like the past it was
just it was kind of funny like a nice
little moment with yeah uncle drugs with
a big heart
yeah cuz he just had he didn't want any
of us to do anything like he was the guy
that I was gonna [ __ ] and he loved
that pop I guess he put down what did
you love yeah yeah but I like the way he
told it is what I meant to say cuz any
was like yeah that she was kind of funny
that's how we ended our you it was so
hard for me because he had that she was
kind of funny c'mon people roll deep man
uncle drugs there was this so Sacramento
there was like a couple of like Hmong
gangs for me being a dumb child had no
idea was a Hmong gang and I thought we
were just friends yeah but they were
there was a group called mo D that
called masters a disaster mmm I thought
it was I thought it was a [ __ ] like
Culture Club dude because you grew up
with these people your whole life and
then you know yo you really cool really
cool [ __ ] man I'm like that's cool bro
but I'm not really mom so I don't want
to join this Culture Club and then my
friend told me is like dude that's a
gang they're not just rights is all this
book all day but it's weird because you
grew up with these people as a kid and
so you don't know what it is you know I
mean so I'm just like oh these are not
good people these teams are jumping
people in high school and stuff I'm like
oh you guys are bad people
I didn't no idea unless they were
jumping bad people oh maybe they would
do some dope [ __ ] though like they were
pretty smart because I remember in high
school there's just one flight worm they
had this distraction where they
literally had two of their [ __ ] gang
members fight each other
quote-unquote and so all the [ __ ]
faculty and staff went there and when
they came over they just [ __ ] jetted
both of them while they were jumping
somebody else on the other side of the
school damn [ __ ] smart did Wow
masters of disaster for real yeah action
masters of distraction 1001 one thing
that I will always remember his do was
this taller with a rice bag for clothes
it was the cutest thing on earth
cuz he walked around and it was just it
was just a [ __ ] he was him in a rice
bag and no arms cuz his arms are inside
right yeah and you see these little legs
just and then he had his group of
friends and he would just trail behind
with his little legs too and then he was
just walking around with the rice bag on
like the white with the green and red
riding on it though it was a burlap
burlap
kind of like rice bag that's cute
they should have sent his picture in for
the humorous and in Hewett he would like
dig a hole and he would squat and [ __ ]
in the morning and every time we walk by
he would wave to us that's cute
[Music]